G
RIGHT NOW.
FELT WORSE OVER THE LAST WEEK
OR.
SO.
>> Jesse: KELLYANNE IS A FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTE AND HERE'S THE
DEAL.
>> KARI LAKE IS GOING TO BE THE
NEXT GOVERNOR.
SHE HAS RAN A TERRIFIC RACE.
RAN A GREAT PRIMARY.
I THINK HER STEADFASTNESS AND
COMMITMENT TO PRINCIPLE IS WHY
SHE IS ALSO GATHERING TOGETHER
MANY INDEPENDENTS HE HAD ARE
TIRED AS DEMOCRATS AS USUAL.
KATIE HOBBS ALREADY AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
SHE IS SECRETARY OF STATE.
SHE IS HIDING.
SHE IS COMPLETING HIDING.
SHE IS EVADING SIMPLE QUESTIONS
I THINK THE LAST REPORTER ASKED
HER WHAT SHE THOUGHT ABOUT THE
WEATHER.
SHE CAN'T ANSWER THAT BUT PUT
OUT A STATEMENT.
SHE WILL HIRE A COMMISSION.
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW THAT THEIR
CANDIDATES OR WOULD BE GOVERNORS
ARE TRANSPARENT AND WILLING TO
LOOK YOU IN THE EYE AND HAVE
THAT CONNECTIVE FISH WITH THE
VOTER.
KARI LAKE DID SOMETHING ELSE
THAT I DON'T THINK GET ENOUGH
COVERAGE.
SHE HAS DONE A MASTERFUL JOB
AFTER WINNING HER PRIMARY
BRINGING TOGETHER THE
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS WHO
OPPOSED HER.
SHE SUPPORTED HER OPPONENT VERY
WELL FUNDED, VERY CREDIBLE
OPPONENT.
AND SHE ALSO HAS THE SUPPORT OF
GOVERNOR DOUG DUCEY WHO IS
PRETTY POPULAR OUT THERE AND WHO
RUNS THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR'S
ASSOCIATION.
THEY SPENT 10-MILLION-DOLLAR ON
THIS RACE.
I THIS I FOR ALL THE HAND
WRINGING ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY BEING DIVIDED AND OH THE
WRONG PEOPLE IN THE PRIMARIES.
IT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
JUST THIS WEEK YOU HAD THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS PUT OUT THIS
RIDICULOUS LETTER TO JOE BIDEN
ASKING HIM TO DEAL WITH PUTIN.
TO RETHINK OUR STRATEGY IN
UKRAINE.
THEY HAVE NOMINATED REALLY
EXTREME CANDIDATES FETTERMAN AND
WISCONSIN WITH BARNES ON AND ON.
KARI LAKES THAT MAGIC SPELL ON
THE MEDIA BECAUSE SHE WAS ONE OF
THEM.
THEY ARE NOT USED TO ONE OF THEM
RUNNING FOR OFFICE, LET ALONE
THIS CONSERVATIVE WOMAN.
THEY SIMPLY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO WITH HER.
SHE CAN ANTICIPATE THEIR
QUESTIONS.
SHE CAN GIVE THEM AS GOOD AS SHE
GETS.
IN ADDITION TO APING THE
QUESTION THAT SHE ASKS.
SHE GOES AND DEFLECTS ON TO
OTHER AREAS AND OTHER ISSUES?
WHY?
BECAUSE SHE HAS THE MIC.
SHE HAS THE PLATFORM.
SHE WANTS TO TELL ARIZONANS WHAT
HER SOLUTIONS TO THE PROBLEMS.
WHEN THEY ASK A RIDICULOUS
QUESTIONS.
BASICALLY ABOUT BEING AN
ELECTION DENIER, SHE IS
ESSENTIALLY IS SAYING MY WORD.
YOU ARE AN INFLATION DENIER.
YOU ARE RECESSION DENIER.
YOU ARE A RISE IN CRIME DENIER.
PEOPLE ARE VERY CONCERNED.
SHE IS OUT THERE SAYING 87,000
NEW IRS AGENTS?
WHAT ABOUT NEW BORDER AGENTS?
WE'RE IN ARIZONA HERE.
SO, I -- LOOK, THE OTHER THING
THAT KARI LAKE REPRESENTS AND IS
NOT ALONE IN THIS REGARD.
IN ADDITION TO FEMALE VOTERS
REALIGNING WITH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY THIS CYCLE.
SOME WOMEN ARE RUNNING AND
WINNING AS REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES.
WE ALREADY HAVE MAYRA FLORES AND
THE SPECIAL ELECTION IN THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY FIRST REPUBLICAN
THERE.
MEXICAN BORN MAYRA FLORES 100
YEARS.
WE HAVE SO MANY WOMEN OUT THERE
BEING ELEVATED AND BEING ELECTED
AS REPUBLICANS.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY ARE -- I
CALL IT THE SAFE WILL, SECURITY
AFFORDABLE SECURITY AND
EDUCATION.
THEY ARE WILLING TO GO OUT THERE
AND TALK ABOUT THOSE ISSUES THAT
THE VOTERS ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAD SO MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT AND
THEY MISSED IT AGAIN AND AGAIN
BY PRETENDING ELECTION IS ONLY
JANUARY 6TH, TRUMP, TRUMP,
ABORTION, CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Jesse: I JUST LOVED HOW KATIE
FRAMED HER OPPONENT FOR BREAKING
IN AND THE NEXT DAY SHE IS LIKE
I DON'T UNDERSTAND TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
ABORTION, ABORTION.
I'M NOT HERE TO DO THAT.
JANUARY 6TH.
I'M NOT HERE TO DO IT.
VOTERS ARE SMART.
I THINK KARI LAKE IS GOING TO BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR.
>> Jesse: KELLYANNE MIGHT BE THE
NEXT FEMALE PRESIDENT.
KELLYANNE GO PHILS.
>>